welcome sorry welcome to this blitz game
playing IL from germany oh I need you to
drink something here tweak it um deform
Slav type of position he's not playing
see form however at the moment he got
was g3 this type of setup you can
basically always play is white it's not
picking sorry very promising with black
being able to put the bishop on that
five but it's certainly playable ok yeah
maybe just 97 challenge this piece huh
ok yeah I should just try to complete
development maybe wants to play him with
the f3 and you form sorry yeah that's
indeed his plan okay so I I was planning
to do this here Bishop f5 was just going
out of this he formed with the temple I
think here white probably has to be
content with e3 taking looks own yeah
really strange so III is probably the
way to go after that Queen B 6 can be
answered with night a form
no I can maybe take I can probably just
take getting me a good structure that's
an altogether weird move should be three
Wow
yeah come on let's just play a normal
natural looking mmm intending e5e form
yeah wouldn't lead to to a very nice
structure I can just take it and it
leaves wide with an isolated pawn on e4
with no great compensation I guess yeah
I'm threatening you 5 p.m. yeah now
probably all the way back to be ADA
covering covering the e5 square
yah White's problem here simply that he
does not control the center with people
with the bones yeah sure double taking
it here on e4 is just giving away g7
that's not not very nice someone I
should play you 5pm v5 if it takes on d5
I take before there is no repairing no
greater compensation or anything ya hear
why it has an additional problem Bishop
c3 fails to Queen B 6 check so probably
Bishop uhm Jung f2 or III yeah bishop
either yeah this is just Queen B 6 check
check winning this boom winning the
snide
I think why Ted had very substantial
problems problems anyway but this is no
head of Lee easy yeah just take here I
guess yeah should I take first on c3
takes on c3a be 591 that's an end game
with an extra piece okay yeah diem
doesn't matter maybe Queen 85 here the
Queen cannot be attacked immediately
yeah I have a form blocking the diagonal
he was attacking b7 using this somewhat
unlucky position of the rook um ok
Knight e5 engine then just castling
taking it next smooth
hmm I should move this Bishop reading 22
to coordinate a bit getting the rooks
connected you know I can I think I can
take it actually 27 at the end is not
not very dangerous but this is simpler I
guess just Bishop back to have six and
take it to take it later yeah here
science to trade queens now
get this whole f3f warm idea is not it's
not really something that belongs into
this position I only need to to get the
get the poor now him
yeah maybe can promote him may I can
promote the opponent white resigned yeah
um everything you cannot cannot play in
that way 9053 I mean this is a bit weird
but probably if white now just develops
normally like Bishop f4 and 92 or
whatever there's not not much happening
it should be basically equal or yet
Bishop f4 this I don't really don't
really don't really like yeah I mean
this should just be fine for black it's
not a very harmonious set up the pieces
are not really controlling the center so
shouldn't be M shouldn't be any any good
however here of course he shouldn't
blunder the the piece I mean I don't
know I really don't know if he goes back
to have to for example here um I'm not
sure that I can take the pawn I mean
need to need to be really sure because
all my king is in the center and there
are ideas like that with this strange
situation here but probably I can just
do this Sam
yeah that that must be good now that
must be good let's say rook here our
computer points out Queen d7 yeah this
is very strong attacking here and
possibly going to see six it also covers
b7 that's the most important part really
so that i can just take it and then
castle yeah your black is winning even
so probably I can take your form yeah
well the whole idea is simply simply
just taken the end yeah it's just a
piece for for nothing okay thanks for
watching